[Musik]
das ärmste land der gesamten arabischen
welt
wie geht es dir um mohammed wie geht es
meiner kann ich ihn untersuchen
über den krieg im jemen erfahren wir im
westen kaum etwas
fast ein jahr hat es gedauert bis wir
als besseres korrespondenten alle
bewilligungen hatten um hinzufahren
[Musik]
es geht um macht und um öl um lokale
identitäten es spielt der konflikt
zwischen dem sunnitischen saudi arabien
und dem schiitischen iran in einem land
das spätestens mit dem gescheiterten
arabischen frühling in die anarchie
abgeglitten ist das ist weil er unter
ernährt ist nicht wegen trockene haut
im jemen herrscht krieg und es herrschen
unzählige kleinkriege
prof
[Musik]
und es herrscht eine unerträgliche arm
das meiste das wir bräuchten um ihn zu
untersuchen fehlt leider
[Musik]
der präsident des internationalen
komitees vom roten kreuz sagt über den
jemen eine solche armut hat nicht einmal
der krieg in syrien oder im irak
ausgelöst
[Musik]
wir beginnen unsere reise in diesen
vergessenen krieg dort wo die folgen am
deutlichsten sind in einem spital
wir besuchen das alpaka spital das
größte öffentliche spital in adern der
hafenstadt ganz an der südspitze des
jemen immer dabei unsere leibwächter
ohne die wir als ausländisches
fernsehteam keinen schritt machen könnte
in den gängen des spitals dutzende
mütter mit ihren kindern
[Musik]
in einem der zimmer ein kleines baby
mohammed ist drei monate alt
in wenigen tagen wird der vier monate
alt sein er wägt 2,9 kilogramm
dabei sollte er fünf oder sechs wiegen
mohammad hatte einen gespaltenen gaumen
dadurch kann er kaum nahrung aufnehmen
ich möchte stellen aber es geht nicht
eine ärztin kommt ins zimmer
die meisten ärzte hier haben seit
monaten kein gehalt mehr bekommen
wer arbeiten kommt tut dies oft
freiwillig
[Musik]
dieser kleine junge ist drei monate
weist er hat seit der geburt seinen
gesprächen wie doppelt gespaltene lücken
deswegen konnte der kleine nicht so viel
nahrung aufnehmen wie ein kind aufnehmen
sollte und deswegen wird er entweder
sterben oder lebenslang probleme starke
unterernährung ist sehr verbreitet
allein in diesem spital haben wir
täglich bis zu 506 neue patienten
der wichtigste grund für unterernährung
ist die armut vieles hin zu arm um sich
genügend nahrung zu kaufen und wir hier
im spital können kaum etwas tun
mohammads ist nicht unterernährt weil es
im jemen nicht genügend nahrung gibt
er ist unterernährt weil er mit einer
gaumenspalte zur welt kam
diese fehlbildung wird normalerweise
operiert nicht so im jänner kein
einziges spital ist hier derzeit in der
lage diese operation durchzuführen
der krieg zwischen deren saudi arabien
geführten koalition gegen die vom iran
unterstützen hufe ist inzwischen ein
ganzes stück von aden entfernt die
frontlinie verläuft heute knapp 300
kilometer weiter nördlich auf unserem
weg entlang der jemenitischen küste
richtung front sind die spuren des
krieges allgegenwärtig nach sechs
stunden fahrt plötzlich ein großer
scheck
die kämpfe am checkpoint sind freundlich
aber auch skeptisch wir werden erst
einmal zur seite gebeten
während die lokalen kommandeuren unsere
bewilligungen prüfen steigen hinter
ihnen kämpfer in ihren gepanzerten
truppentransportern eine uniform trägt
hier keiner
manche der männer scheinen sehr jung zu
sein
endlich dürfen auch wir weiterfahren
wir gelangen nachmacher einer kleinstadt
gut 250 kilometer nördlich von art am
rande der stadt die kommando basis der
koalition
der krieg im jemen geht eigentlich
zurück bis ins jahr 1990 damals hatten
sich die zuvor geteilten nord und
südjemen wiedervereinigt doch anstatt
zusammen zu wachsen begann die
zentralregierung in sanaa alte
machtstrukturen zu zerstören und
lukrative einnahmequellen wie öl an sich
zu reißen als im zuge des arabischen
frühlings langzeitherrscher ali abdullah
saleh von der macht verjagt wurde
eskalierte der machtkampf um die
kontrolle des staatsapparates und damit
der einnahmequelle
das sind die eigentlichen gründe dieses
krieges
[Musik]
rund um den stützpunkt herrscht rege
aktivität
doch uns wollen die kommandeure der
koalition offenbar nicht empfangen
wir beschließen weiter ins städtchen
hineinzufahren auch hier sind die spuren
des krieges unübersehbar ausländischer
soldaten der koalition wie diese aus dem
sudan westliche panzerwagen ein
versenktes kriegs
für die von den vereinigten arabischen
emiraten und saudi arabien angeführte
koalition ist mache ein strategischer
punkt es ist ihr ausgangspunkt zum
angriff auf raider dem wichtigsten hafen
des landes
dieser liegt keine 200 kilometer weiter
nördlich von mo am roten meer
wir fahren durch die erst kürzlich
zurückeroberte stand
da uns die kommandeure der koalition
nicht empfangen wollen versuchen wir
einen der lokalen milizenführer zu
treffen
doch auch hier müssen wir erst einmal
warten
die kämpfer des milizenführer sladen uns
zum mittagessen ein raise mit lamm das
tägliche essen an der front
die who sie sind ja genau die sind weit
weg
100 kilometern
dann taucht der milizenführer endlich
auf abu ahmad hat uns gerade lange genug
warten lassen um seine macht zu
demonstrieren
aber er hat uns gleichzeitig bewertet
als zeichen der freundlichkeit mit
seinen männern ist abu ahmad für die
innere sicherheit des örtchens zuständig
mit gottes hilfe und dank gott werden
die sunnitische widerstandskämpfer und
unserer armee den sieg davontragen
wir werden dies tun mit der hilfe der
saudischen armee und dank der männer aus
den emiraten und von abo bin sajed und
dank der westlichen koalition
es ist offensichtlich aber ahmadis zwar
der chef mache aber alleine macht
passiert auf ausländische unterstützung
das macht den krieg im jemen zu
kompliziert die who sie eine schiitische
widerstandsbewegung aus dem grenzgebiet
zu saudi arabien eroberten 2014 den
norden mit der hauptstadt sanaa und der
küste des roten meeres und drangen
schließlich bis nach aden vor 2015 griff
eine von saudi arabien geführte
arabische allianz aus zehn arabischen
und afrikanischen ländern ein
mit loyalen jemenitischen truppen
kontrollieren sie heute den süden und
osten des landes
doch gleichzeitig nutzen al qaida der s
und andere dschihadisten gruppen das
chaos zudem entstand eine neue starke
südjemenitischen separatistenbewegung
ein weiterer kommandant trifft ein
abu mohammed ist der sicherheitschef für
die umgebung von macher mit gottes hilfe
kommen wir dem sieg immer näher
die jungs hier kämpfen stark und die
moral an der front draußen ist gut wir
haben schon viele orte von den ruf wie
befreit und wir werden noch viele mehr
befreien
wir rufen unsere männer dazu auf diesen
siegeszug fort zu setzen
und wir rufen sie dazu auf an die
fronten zu strömen und zu siegen
bis wir die hufe die unser land zerstört
habe
ausgelöscht haben
abu mohammed will uns etwas zeigen
gegen den anderen wagen aber auch mal
soll mit seinem wagen fahren er ist der
verantwortliche für dieses gebiet
nora ist strategisch wichtig durch den
hafen hier konnten die hoch wie damals
alle ihre waffen einschmuggelt waffen
die laut abu muhammad vor allem aus dem
iran zu den häufig gelangen inter den
hufen steht der iran der iran und andere
mit dem iran verbündete gruppierungen
unterstützen die hu si es ist einfach
für sie es ist einfach alles mögliche
nach ihnen zu schmuggeln
denn auch wenn die koalition eine
seeblockade verhängt hat wir haben viele
kleine häfen hier und die jemenitische
küste ist lang
sicherungs bitte da vorne ab
euro
das ist okay
falls die hufe frieden wollen müssen sie
sicher geben
sie haben keine andere wahl wir sind
stark genug und haben den willen zu
kämpfen bis wir sie ausgelöst haben oder
bis sie sich ergeben
davon scheint uns die militärallianz von
jemeniten saudi arabien und emiraten
allerdings weiter entfernt als uns dies
abu mohammed glauben machen will
auch wenn die koalition hier rundum moha
die lage im griff hat und stärke
demonstriert ein ende des krieges ist
auch nach drei jahren nicht in sicht
und schon jetzt ist abzusehen dass die
lokalen kommandeure ihre neugewonnenen
gründe auch nach einem ende der kämpfe
nicht einfach wieder aufgeben werden
[Musik]
zurückziehen
die wehrlosesten opfer in einem krieg
sind immer die kinder auch im jemen
und doch ist es hier noch schlimmer als
in den meisten anderen kriegsgebieten in
denen wir waren
das schicksal des kleinen mohammed dem
unterernährten baby mit dem gespaltenen
gaumen geht uns nicht aus dem kopf wir
fahren erneut zum als ataka spital
die sicherheitsvorkehrungen sind selbst
hier in einem öffentlichen spital rigide
jedenfalls mehr unterwegs
mohammed lebt aber er ist äußerst
schwach
[Musik]
sein zustand ist ernst sehr ernst
mohammed hat kaum kraft nicht einmal zum
weinen
der vater von mohammed steht nebenan
seine verzweiflung ist mit händen zu
greifen falls er genügend gewicht
erreicht kann er dann operiert werden
normalerweise muss er ein jahr als seien
für eine solche operation zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt ist es sehr schwierig vor
allem aus den gespaltenen gaumen
betrifft sein mund wird zu bleiben bis
er älter ist als ein jahr
die lippe das könnte man früher machen
aber nicht wenn er drei monate alt ist
und zwei kilo wiegt ich habe gehört man
könne eine solche operation mit sechs
monaten machen ja aber nicht wenn ein
baby zwei kilogramm wiegt wegen der
narkose gründe für mohammeds gespaltenen
gaumen kann es viele geben
mangelernährung und stress der
schwangeren mutter können erheblichen
einfluss haben mohammads eltern sind
hilflos und überfordert
der arzt sagte mohammed gehe es besser
dass das nicht die wahrheit ist spürt
hier im raum jeder
[Musik]
mein sohn tut mir so leid aber wir
können nicht mehr als dem schicksal
vertrauen und akzeptieren was gott für
uns entscheidet als wir die familie an
diesem abend verlassen glauben wir nicht
mehr dass wir den kleinen mohammed noch
einmal lebend wiedersehen werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier im süden des jemen in der
hafenstadt aden hat die koalition aus
lokalen saudischen und emiratischen
truppen die hufe schon vor drei jahren
aus der stadt vertrieben
[Musik]
heute ist aden eine mischung aus
explosivem kessel und dem versuch
zurückzukehren
zur normalität
ich backe brot wenn eines kombis ist
dass die traditionelle art er es ist
eine uralte methode um brot zu backen
das größte problem sind die ständig
steigenden preise alles wird teurer und
teurer
dabei fällt der strom ständig aus und
auch wasser ist rar
das sind momentan die größten probleme
solange es einigermaßen sicher sein sie
zufrieden sagen die leute und laden uns
zum tee ein
hier im zentrum von aden fühlt sich der
alltag an wie ihn so manch anderer
arabischer staat auch doch der schein
trügt der international anerkannte
präsident des jemen mansur hadi hat
abends war zu seiner vorübergehenden
hauptstadt gemacht
doch hardy lebt vorwiegend in saudi
arabien während sich in adern warlords
dschihadisten separatisten und selbst
die eigentlich verbündeten saudi arabien
und die emirate gegenseitig bekämpfen
der krieg im jemen ist hochkomplex
selbst die einwohner verstehen oft nicht
wer nun genau gegen wen kämpft
ich versuche einfach meine arbeit zu
machen
die miete zu bezahlen und die
stromrechnung für alles andere verlasse
ich mich auf gott mohammed um den abriss
samt während des krieges gegen die
häufig verlief die frontlinie genau hier
entlang direkt vor mohammed denn das
geschäft
während des krieges war die lage schon
sehr brenzlig hier
ich habe jeweils nur eine tür geöffnet
und den leuten mal durch diese eine tür
hälfte hindurch verkauft die kugeln
flogen vor meinem laden nur so herum huf
scharfschütze zumindest diese zeiten
sind in aden inzwischen vorbei wir
reisen weiter hinaus aus der stadt
hier beginnt schnell al kaida
unsere beschützer werden nervös das
entführungsrisiko wird hier groß auf dem
weg richtung norden immer wieder aus
gebaute häuser zerstörte
militärfahrzeuge unser ziel ein
flüchtlingslager
wir haben schon viele lager in
kriegsgebieten gesehen aber so etwas
noch nicht
zelte die keine zelte sind hütten die
keine hütten sind ein paar vertrocknete
erste die zerrissene planen zusammenhalt
diese flüchtlinge gehören zu einer der
ärmsten volksgruppen indien sie haben
gar nichts die frauen und mädchen
schützen ihre gesichter mit purem lehm
gegen sonne sand die hitze mehr als 2000
menschen teilen sich eine einzige
toilette
es gibt keine medizinische versorgung
keinen strom die beiden einzigen
wassertanks sind lag ein spielplatz für
die kinder oder gar eine schule
inexistent hilfe kommt hier fast keine
an zu gefährlich zu abgelegen
wir werden auf eine junge frau
aufmerksam die regungslos am boden sitzt
reali ist 20 jahre alt und gelähmt seit
dem tag als die kampfjets kamen
ich habe geschlafen heißt die bomben
fielen
die mauer unseres hauses stürzte direkt
auf machen ich habe nichts gespürt ich
hörte nur meine mutter schreien meine
kinder ich wusste nicht was los war aber
als ich aufstehen wollte konnte ich
meine beine nicht mehr bewegen
[Musik]
reale und ihre familie kommen als times
das ist jene stadt im zentrum des landes
in welcher der krieg besonders heftig
wütet
weißt du wer weshalb gegen wen kämpft in
diesem krieg wir haben diesen krieg
wegen der who sie sagen sie die mutter
von leni erinnert sich genau an die
nacht in der die bomben fielen
die nachbarn kamen angerannt um zu
helfen
sie brachten uns zu einem spital aber
der arzt verlangte geld und ich hatte
kein geld also brachten wie reale zu
einem anderen arzt aber der konnte nicht
wirklich was für sie tun
deshalb kann sie jetzt nicht mehr gehen
ein mühlstein ist das einzige was sah
fachmarkt aus thais mitgebracht hat es
ist hart hier
wir haben kein wasser um zu putzen es
gibt keine toiletten kein bart auch
trinkwasser gibt es kaum
und es wird immer heißer
im durchschnitt erkranken täglich 5000
jemeniten an kohler alle zehn minuten
stirbt ein kind aus vermeidbaren grund
gemäss dem unabhängigen netzwerk jemand
data project gilt nur ein drittel der
saudischen luftangriffe jeweils
gesichert militärischen ziel der rest
trifft unschuldige menschen kinder wie
den achtjährigen 8 da kam ein flugzeug
es war eine bombe ab die splitter haben
ihn getroffen
[Musik]
die bombe riss in den arm und das bein
weg
das sind zwei prothesen der arm wurde
von hier abgerissen das bein ab hier der
blick des jungen ist für uns fast nicht
auszuhalten
was ist genau geschehen
ich hab schafe gehütet und eine rakete
hat mich getroffen
das ist geschehen ja woher die rakete
kam weiß ich nicht geschichten wie
diejenige vom 8 hören wir in jeder
einzelnen dieser zelltyp die menschen
die hier gestrandet sind haben nichts
mehr keine heimat keinen besitz keine
zukunft
[Musik]
auch der 6 jährigen sarah hilft niemand
sarah wurde von einem querschläger
getroffen
zwar hat eine kugel im kopf
sie steckt immer noch drin wie können
sie nicht ausnehmen auf dem röntgenbild
ist die kugel deutlich zu sehen
er selbst sagt kein wort
doch aus ihren augen spricht zorn zorn
über das was die welt ihr angetan hat
und über das was hier kaum einer
versteht
wir haben keine ahnung wofür dieser
krieg gut sein soll
wir wissen nur unsere häuser brennen
bomben treffen uns das ist alles über
10.000 tote hat dieser krieg bisher
gefordert mehr als zwei millionen
menschen wurden zu flüchtlingen im
eigenen land die uno nennt den krieg im
jemen die schlimmste humanitäre
katastrophe des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
der krieg hat jemand so zerstört und in
die armut gewarnt dass das land mit
sämtlichen grundbedürfnissen versorgt
werden muss doch nahrungsmittel wasser
elektrizität treibstoff oder medikamente
gelangen kaum ins land wir fahren zur
küstenwache in aden
[Musik]
oberst marbach sie nimmt uns mit auf
patrouillenfahrt oberst baksi hat gerade
noch zwei kleine boote die seetüchtig
sind erfährt uns an wracks vorbei das
waren seine schiffe mit denen die
küstenwache früher patriot während der
schlacht um aden haben die who die sie
versenkt das da ist der zoll freihafen
mit dem container deck dort drüben dass
es der maler hafen der hafen durch den
eigentlich güter ins land gelangen
sollten aber interne konflikte
verhindern dass manchmal kommt ein
schiff mit hilfsgütern mit medikamenten
oder nahrungsmitteln aber wir dürfen es
nicht reinlassen weil es an der hafen
leitung liegt diese bewilligung zu
erteilen es sind diese kleinen kriege
innerhalb des großen krieges die auch
dazu führen dass hilfslieferungen
blockiert werden hier in aden streiten
sich sogar die beiden verbündeten saudi
arabien und die vereinigten arabischen
emirate um die vorherrschaft
die beiden blockieren sich vor dem krieg
vor 2015 waren wir verantwortlich für
den hafen hier aber seit dem krieg
herrscht kontrollieren andere kräfte den
hafen
arbeitet ihr zusammen oder ist es eher
schwierig er letzteres sagen ja so diese
leute sind nicht gut darin einen hafen
le malade zu sichern
sie sind keine spezialisten deutlichere
worte kann ein oberster jemenitischen
küstenwache nicht wählen wenn er
gefahrlos ausdrücken will
dass erde muskelspiel zwischen saudi
arabien und den emiraten machtlos
ausgeliefert ist ein muskelspiel das
dazu führt dass die wenigen
hilfslieferungen die überhaupt noch
kommen manchmal monatelang im hafen
liegen bleiben bis die ware verdorben
ist
die zerstörung im jemen ist immens
seit beginn des krieges führte die von
saudi arabien angeführte koalition fast
17.000 luftschläge durch die bomben
treffen dabei längst nicht nur
militärische ziele
diese tür hat schon lange niemand mehr
geöffnet
dabei strömt durch diese tür für täglich
eine ganze horde von jugendlichen
es ist das tor zum gymnasium von macht
einem kleinen ort rund eine autostunde
außerhalb von aden
auch seien außer kraft ging hier zur
schule
es waren zwei bomben eine hier und die
andere dort die schule wurde bombardiert
weil sich uci kämpfer hier einquartiert
hatten
was ist das hier das ist die uniform
eines der getöteten
die who sie waren hier der luftschlag
alpinen weißt du wie viele menschen bei
dem luftschlag getötet worden
ich glaube es waren 33
du willst es nicht berühren wie nein da
klebt immer noch blut dran
alles liegt noch so da wie nach jenem
tag als die bomben fielen
ich glaube
das ist ein system von von pflanzen
denke ich wie viele menschen im jemen
sein ist wütend auf saudi arabien die
saudis sollten wenigstens unsere schule
wieder aufbauen
sie haben sie zerstört also sollen sie
sie wieder aufbauen
das war unser ehemaliges klassenzimmer
alles zerstört wo hast du bis essen wo
hast du gesessen
das da das war mein platz sein hat zu
hause weiter gelernt und studiert heute
in aden medizin viele seiner mitschüler
haben das nicht geschafft
bis jetzt haben wir noch keinerlei
wiederaufbauhilfe erhalten schule hält
hier keiner mehr
das schlägt sich auf unsere bildung
nieder
andere können zur schule gehen wir haben
keine schulen mehr
laut jemand art project einem projekt
jemenitischen aktivisten die versuchen
licht ins dunkel des weitgehend
unbeachteten krieges zu bringen hat die
saudisch geführte militärallianz seit
beginn des krieges vor drei jahren
241 schulen bombardiert 241 schulen als
wir den ort verlassen begegnet uns diese
szenerie die ziemlich exakt
zusammenfasst was im jemen gerade
geschieht
der jemen war schon vor diesem krieg das
ärmste land der arabischen welt jetzt
bomben modernste auch westliche waffen
das land und sein bildungswesen noch
weiter zurück in der entwicklung
wir besuchen noch einmal den kleinen
mohammed und sind überrascht dass wir
ihn und seine mutter seien in einem
anderen zimmer vorfinden
vielleicht auch weil sich unsere
besucher herumgesprochen haben durfte
mohammed in eines der vier betten auf
der intensivstation
dies dann war er extrem müde er bekam
keine luft mehr
nach sechs stunden gaben sie ihm endlich
sauerstoff die behandlung hat offenbar
etwas geholfen
seit heute nachmittag geht es ihm
spürbar besser die leiterin der
intensivstation ist ebenfalls
erleichtert was können sie hier mehr für
ihn tun
das erste ist dass in diesem raum nur
vier patienten sind dann ist immer eine
krankenschwester rund um die uhr
er wird also immer überwacht dazu hat
der permanente sauerstoffversorgung
wenige tage zuvor hatte nicht nur wir
den eindruck dass der kleine mohammed
bereit war zu sterben
doch heute spüren wir neuen lebenswillen
in seinem kleinen könnten
er ist deutlich weniger gestresst als
zuvor
er akzeptiert nahrung das fieber ist
gesunken er ist weniger angespannt er
reagiert auf uns es geht ihm also besser
wird er überleben
wir hoffen es es wäre ein leben gegen
alle widerstände
am hafen von aden finden wir die reste
des historischen eingangs todes während
der kämpfe in der stadt wurden hier 43
menschen getötet
die schutz gesucht hat in den trümmern
sitzt ein junger mann
der jemen ist verelenden verwüstet und
ein hoffnungsloser fall
mohamed raschid hatte pläne aber keine
chancen
keine worte um zu beschreiben was das
mit ihr macht das leben ist einfach nur
eine riesige enttäuschung
was auch immer du dir für pläne aus
denkst du wirst enttäuscht drees dich im
kreis in einem leeren kreis das ist die
beste beschreibung du bewegst dich im
vakuum im nichts im westen wäre mohammed
raschid ein begehrter mann er ist
englisch lehrer und politologe doch der
krieg hat die wirtschaftliche krise und
die korruption dramatisch verschärft ich
habe nichts alles was ich mache
ich schlage meine zeit tot ich
verschwende meine zeit wenn du deine
zeit verschwendet verschwindest du auch
dein leben derzeit bedeutet liegt
so wie mohammed raschid geht es
tausenden von jungen jemeniten doch
flüchten können die wenigsten die
grenzen zu saudi arabien sind
abgeriegelt und auf der anderen seite
des meeres liegt somalia
wir verlassen den hafen und tauchen ein
in ein aden wie wir es nicht erwartet
hätte
[Musik]
baden lebt und wie
wir finden uns wieder auf einem fest
dass eine mischung ist aus musicstar
talentshow stand up comedy und ganz
einfach einer riesigen party
[Musik]
das örtliche fernsehen berichtet live
und wäre nicht überall bewaffnete wachen
man könnte glatt vergessen wo man ist
[Applaus]
höhepunkt des abends ist der auftritt
eines der bekanntesten stand up
comedians handels mohamed el erian
wegen ihm sind wir hier ich komme zu
spät ich weiß aber vorher waren
regierungs leute hier
zur hölle mit ihnen komiker larry spielt
eine alte frau eine figur die hier so
bekannt ist wie in der schweiz harry
hasler oder emil durch den mund der
alten frau kann er ja nie aussprechen
was er sonst nicht aussprechen könnte
ich muss mal über euch sprechen
liebe frauen über eure mode so viele
verschiedene bayern das ist ja
wahnsinnig ihr girls seht aus wie
weihnachtsbäume so viel glitzer und
glimmer von oben bis unten und von
hinten bis vorne glitter selbst die in
selbstverständlich meistens schwarz
gekleideten frauen finden es lustig doch
das gilt nicht für alle in atem
der komiker lebt gefährlich
[Musik]
normalerweise sage ich was ich will
auch wenn gerade wieder ein paar leute
versucht haben mich umzubringen
wie sah es mit vier freunden in einem
auto und wir wurden mit fünf schüssen
beschossen
andere leute haben mich angerufen und
gesagt sie seien vom ios oder von al
kaida und sie würden mich töten wenn ich
nicht aufhören würde ich habe ihnen
gesagt dass ich weitermache auch wenn
sie versuchen würden mich umzubringen
eine fernsehshow mit ariane wurde
abgesetzt
die tv bosse waren mit seinen kritischen
kommentaren nicht einverstanden
es gibt so viele probleme in meinem land
ich benutze diese figur aber eigentlich
spreche ich nur als bürger ich sage was
ich als bürger von meiner regierung will
ich will strom ich will fließendes
wasser
ich will ein funktionierendes telefon
ganz alltägliche sache das versuche ich
durch meine figur zu sagen wenn ich auf
der bühne stehen
die regierenden kritisiere ich weil die
meistens nur im ausland leben
von dort befehle erteilen und nicht
betroffen sind von dem was wir hier zu
spüren bekommen
wir treffen erneut feisal und sarah drei
monate sind inzwischen vergangen
sie tragen mohammed zum flughafen mit
viel hilfe von außen hat es die familie
geschafft dass sie nach jordanien
fliegen kann
in amman kann der nun sechs monate alte
mohammed die hilfe erhalten
hier im jemen nicht bekommen kann und
ohne die er sterben würde
wie heißt dieses quartier im sunnyside
der neue ja wir sind das erste mal hier
im taxi erzählt feisal was seit unserem
letzten besuch in seiner heimat passiert
ist in dem spital in dem er mohammed
zuletzt war hat ein soldat einen arzt
angegriffen
daraufhin trat das gesamte spital für
zwei monate in einen streik was geschah
mit den kindern die anderen kinder die
mit mohammed auf der intensivstation
lagen sind alle gestorben
alle außer mohammed gestorben mohameds
erhält dank der hilfe einer kuwaitischen
ngo eine chance zum leben
die organisation kommt für die operation
in amman auf
weil sie noch flott ist der kinderarzt
der alles eingefädelt hat er sieht den
kleinen mohammed nun zum ersten mal und
erschlägt nicht und aus die aus aden
haben uns gesagt mohammed liege
fünfeinhalb kilogramm jetzt sehen wir
erwähnt nur 4
damit ist mohammed eigentlich viel zu
leicht für eine so schwere operation für
den kleinen und seine eltern beginnt ein
langer tag mit einer untersuchung nach
der anderen
[Musik]
es übersteigt sein kopf ist heiß
mohammed soll gesenkt werden
denn er hatte in seinem kurzen leben
schon mehrere lungeninfektionen diese
konnten wegen des medikamenten mangels
im jemen nicht angemessen behandelt
werden
auch jetzt entdecken die ärzte eine
entzündete
was haben sie mit dir gemacht
die ärzte beraten was zu tun ist der
narkose arzt hat große bedenken
es kann sein dass er aufwacht und alles
ist okay aber es kann auch sein dass wir
ihn eine zeit lang künstlich beatmen
müssen das können zwei stunden seien ein
tag zwei tage und es kann auch sein gott
behüte dass es nicht gut ausgeht
verstehen sie er kann sterben
wie groß ist dieses risiko das weiß
nämlich es kann sein dass er aufwacht
und alles ist gut aber es kann auch sein
dass er nicht mehr aufwacht
für die eltern bricht eine welt zusammen
am nächsten morgen soll die operation
stattfinden
doch die ärzte entscheiden sich dagegen
mohammad hatte über nacht hohes fieber
dazu durchfall und mir zu atmen
die situation ist die dame hat so hohes
fieber hat können wir ihn nicht die
narkose setzen wir wollen auch dass er
besser aber ich werde euch medikamente
geben
die operation wird erst einmal
verschoben
das fieber macht umsorgen er wisse nicht
ob es mit mohammed atmungs problemen
zusammenhängt er hat einen ausschlag auf
der brust oder mit dem magen darm infekt
den er entwickelt hat wir müssen
abwarten
[Musik]
er hat fieber aber seine stimme ist
lauter heute er atmet besser in der
nacht konnte er kaum atmen
es ging so er hat im grunde
heute geht es ihm besser fast schon wie
immer er ist viel ruhiger
[Musik]
viel zeit hat mohammed nicht faul und
zahna können nicht ewig in amman bleiben
wenn die operation nicht bald
stattfindet müssen sie zurück in den
jemen ohne dass mohammed geholfen werden
konnte
es wird eine schwere nach
der dritte tag beginnt mit einer
überraschung sarah und verbringen
mohammed zum operationssaal das fieber
ist über nacht gesunken
der atem geht regelmäßig deshalb haben
die ärzte beschlossen dass mohammed
heute operiert werden soll
wie heißt er mohammed mohamed auf
wiedersehen auf wiedersehen alles wird
gut
riffert als ekici ist einer der besten
chirurgen in ganz jordanien
er ist spezialisiert auf fälle wie
mohammed
mohammed ist ein ganz schwieriger fall
für die wiederherstellung aber auch für
den narkosearzt erwägt viel zu wenig
sein ganzer zustand ist schlecht die
operation ist tatsächlich schwierig drei
stunden später
die operation ist vorbei mohammad sollte
aufwachen und tatsächlich der kleine
junge öffnet seine augen
ich hatte solche angst um ihn
ich habe mir solche sorgen gemacht jetzt
geht es mir so viel besser der kleine
mohammed hat es vorerst geschafft
in sechs monaten wartet die nächste
operation auf ihn dann wohl in kuwait
schon in ein zwei tagen wird er wieder
in den jemen reisen
jemen ist kein guter ort für kinder
alles ist zerstört die ganze situation
die krankheiten auch die schulen kaputt
dieser krieg hat alles zunichte gemacht
komplett zunichte gemacht
für den kleinen mohammed gibt es
zumindest so etwas wie einen kleinen
hoffnungsschimmer
der krieg im jemen zerstört leben
hoffnungen träumen
eine lösung ist weit entfernt die
menschen die wir auf unserer reise
kennengelernt haben kämpfen um ihr leben
ihre zukunft gegen den zerfall
ich will jemen wieder aufbauen
jedes kind soll hoffnung haben können in
diesem land deshalb will ich es wieder
aufbauen und mithelfen dass etwas
entsteht das so schön ist wie amerika
wie die türkei die länder in europa nur
ist zwölf und will architektin werden
sie und ihre familie sind unsere letzte
begegnung hier in aber ich will meine
träume nicht aufgeben wegen den krieg
ich werde mein land wieder aufbauen und
die hürden überwinden
was auch immer es braucht ich werde mein
land wieder aufbauen
zum abschied sinkt nur für uns ein lied
es ist eine liebeserklärung ans
heimatland
die dir blöd
[Musik]